Je veux vous parler d'un homme que j'ai connu une fois,
il a laissé toute sa vie sous un grand
scanner en boucle, alors il a quitté sa
maison au sommet de la terre, il est venu
dans le sud pour le reste d'entre nous, vivons un
esquimau bizarre J'ai un important
message attends laisse-moi prendre ça du
haut ton nom est Teddy sceau sur une mission
de Dieu de mes aînés à propos de la fin
du monde nous dans le Sud il fait de
très mauvaises choses et le Soleil a eu un coup de pied
et il descend pour me casser  J'ai besoin
de parler à vos aînés
maintenant pourquoi était-il
tous les dirigeants du monde cette
rencontre intérieure mr.  Nations Unies,
vous ne pouvez pas aller dans ce joint ressemblant à un
Eskimo, nous voulons les filmer, je suis en train d'être
filmé
[Musique]
J'ai entendu votre histoire sur le Soleil et j'ai
trouvé ça fascinant,
c'est ici que vous sauvez le monde que nous sommes
à la recherche d'entreprises qui veulent
parrainer un événement que Theo est végétalien il est
temps pour une révolution une révolution de
l'esprit je dois dire que vous avez un
impact considérable avec cette histoire
ils ne pensent pas à ce qu'ils
ne peuvent pas faire ils pensent  à propos de ce
qu'ils peuvent vous inspirer
pourquoi êtes-vous si intéressé par ce gars Je
vois l'innocence et le but
Je n'ai pas cru en quoi que ce soit depuis
trop longtemps
[Musique]
Oh Davis
oui alors grimpe ou
[Musique]